[Music]
so I saw your Harry Potter and Hunger
Games since videos yeah yeah read the
book home so any movie that's based on a
book I have to read the book first yeah
okay all the President's Men and movies
based on a book and I've never read it
the movies awesome you won't want cuz
they explain everything and that movies
entertaining
you're comparing than Harry Potter and
Hunger Games can make use of political
stories of our time to fantasy now let's
just say that all the President's Men
didn't explain everything right maybe
there's a phone call or a clandestine
parking lot meeting where we don't get
to see it and all of a sudden Woodward
and Bernstein know all about Watergate
but we didn't see how they learned right
you would sit there and tell me to go
read the book well I would go probably
all you would say you know don't worry
about it maybe you could figure it out
in five seconds if you just think about
that you're sure I can figure out that
somebody told them somebody probably
worked in the White House but I don't
know who it is I don't understand their
motivation how did they get this person
to talk when no one was you make movies
like Harry Potter for people who read
the books both studio executives would
throw themselves off a bridge if they
made book money all right you tell me
the only people they want to enjoy this
movie or the people who read the book
makers can't put everything from a book
into the movie why does it matter if
haggart's dragging a tree what the
is wrong with you I'll tell you why
magic I'm watching a movie about magic
and they're making this poor bastard
drag a giant tree all the way across
campus it's a married to Darrin from
bewitched in some kind of a gay pact why
does the pact have to be cannot do magic
listen it's all explained in the book
right yeah well that's another thing why
do I even care what you people who read
the book thing you people are the
hardest to please in the world even to
pick everything oh they changed the boa
constrictor into a Burmese python or
they didn't do peeves the poltergeist or
they left out the Sorting Hat song but
if I point out one inconsistency in the
movie you tell me go read the book makes
everything better right they wouldn't
ask this many stupid questions while
we're on the subject of magic it means
that like the force you have to believe
that you have it before you actually
have it I mean they're all sitting
around waving wands and doing the pseudo
Latin and I mean if it really comes down
to who pronounces it the best and
they're really just taking language
courses I think it's like what Malcolm
Gladwell said it takes like 10,000 hours
practice to become a puzzlin money
should be the best Wizard of the whole
series and all she ever does is read
study correct people and go to the
library and she's a better wizard than
Ron she's a better wizard than Harry
probably better wizard than Dumbledore
Dumbledore definitely has more than
10,000 hours of practice that's why he
does magic in one movie at 8:00
[Music]